c'est une guerre dans la guerre qui
divise un pays déjà bien fragilisé par
les conflits communautaires et les
interventions étrangères
alors qu'ils sont en principe alliés
contre les rebelles houthi le
gouvernement yéménite et les
séparatistes du conseil de transition du
sud
le stc se disputent le contrôle du sud
du yémen
l'accord de ryad a signé en novembre
2019 prévoyait pourtant un partage du
pouvoir dans cette partie du territoire
mais ces dispositions n'ont quasiment
jamais été en vigueur jusqu'à ce que les
saoudiens propose un plan pour accélérer
sa mise en oeuvre
il prévoit notamment la nomination d'un
nouveau gouvernement d'ici à 30 jours
ainsi que celle d'un nouveau
gouvernement à aden la capitale du sud
du pays où sont basés les séparatistes
de quoi satisfaire le porte parole du
stc le conseil de transition annonce
l'abandon de la déclaration d'auto
gouvernance afin de permettre à
l'alliance arabes de mettre en oeuvre
l'accord de rien
nous affirmons la poursuite et
l'approfondissement de notre partenariat
stratégique avec l'alliance arabe à tous
les niveaux politique militaire
économique et sécuritaire à travers nos
objectifs communs de lutte contre l'
ingérence iranienne dans la région
contre les groupes terroristes et contre
les activités des extrémistes
ce consensus trouvé entre ryad et les
séparatistes du stc redonne de l'espoir
aux acteurs des négociations selon le
vice ministre saoudien de la défense
grâce aux efforts du prince héritier il
a été possible de réunir le gouvernement
yéménite et le conseil de transition du
sud pour qu'ils s'accordent sur le
mécanisme proposé par l'arabie saoudite
afin de mettre en oeuvre l'accord de
ryad et d'instaurer la paix la sécurité
et une prospérité durable au yémen en
parallèle d'autres négociations sont en
cours depuis quatre mois entre le
gouvernement et les rebelles houthi
l'envoyé spécial de l'onu pour le yémen
déplore que les discussions soient
longues et difficiles et affirme que le
pays traverse les pires moments de son
histoire
le yémen est en effet dévasté par la
guerre brutale que mène la coalition
saoudienne contre les outils depuis du
1015 une guerre qui non seulement
détruit le pays mais qui a également tué
au moins 100 mille civils et rendu les
deux tiers de la population soit 24
millions de personnes dépendant d'une
assistance humanitaire toujours plus
rares